foreign
Caleb joins us in Cincinnati Caleb
welcome to the Ramsay show
God bless you gentlemen how y'all doing
good what's your car payment
550. there we go all right you're below
average what are we celebrating this now
I'm so confused how can we help today
well my main question I owe 19 000 left
on my car it's my one transportation to
work
um do I just take this punch and just
get it paid off and never make this
mistake again should I look to refinance
should I look to get get it off my hands
how much is it worth
[Music]
um
they say at the auction it's a lot less
it's it's a 2019 Toyota Corolla how many
miles
um 80 000. what's the Kelly Blue Book on
that
I honestly don't know you need to know
there's some homework you got to do and
check for private sale we're not going
to take this thing to auction if you
want to get the best bang for your buck
this it's going to be through a private
sale
you can also check sites like carvana
and vroom and those kinds of uh online
what was the year
2019 2019 Toyota Corolla 80 000 miles
Ken is doing his due diligence here
doing the research for you to be a good
guy well I mean this takes just moments
well he does that idea to help him out
George I'll give him some reason what's
your income
uh 32 a month 32 a month is that take
home or is that gross
um that is take home okay I mean it's a
lot of car for your income it's not
outside the bounds we say that you know
we don't want more than 50 percent of
your income tied up and things with
motors I've got an update George all
right give us all right this is carvana
a national uh brand and they've got a uh
a used uh Toyota 2019 Toyota Corolla 79
000 miles that's right about where
you're at 21-5
but again if you sell this privately and
you come in a little bit under what the
car dealers are asking for you can move
this thing and not have to go to auction
that's all I wanted to tell you it's an
option as George walks you through do
you have any money saved how much do you
have in cash zero I don't have anything
saved yeah okay how quickly could you
save up a few thousand dollars
um you're gonna you're getting side jobs
we're selling other stuff how quickly
could you save up five grand
if if I go back to my second job um I
can make it in a month okay could you
pay off the car the 19k if you really
hustled
realistically if I really really push uh
a year how much other debt do you have
I have I there it's like 30 000 total
um seven of it is tied up in student
loans
um I I don't know what I'm gonna do with
that
um and then the other stuff is like
medical me and my wife got married so my
my silly young butt put rings on there
like I got two thousand dollars with the
Rings the silly stuff is your wife
working outside the home
no we have a nine-month-old daughter oh
congratulations thank you well this
one's gonna be on you we're going to get
back to that second job we're going to
get the income up I'm okay with you
keeping it but I want you to have a very
aggressive goal of how quickly we're
paying it off
what's her car worth does she have one
she does not okay then that means we're
within the parameters here
my plan was to to stay with this one and
pay it off and save on the side and get
her something you know that is safe or
whatever even if I had to get a little
Honda Civic that I can take the work and
let her and the baby use this car I want
to get a second vehicle but
I just
every time I hear 19 000 and I mean have
you
have you done the research on what you
can get for five thousand dollars
um I have
um as far as like
um
what is it let go or whatever you know
the Facebook Marketplace it's a private
little fail like that but uh
um is that is that what you would
suggest I am suggesting you research it
I I don't disagree with George I think
that you can go work your tail off and
make some really good money and begin to
pay all of the debt down using our debt
snowball I mean you know the 19 000 I
think is your largest debt uh but as it
relates to 550 a month I believe you
said if that were to come off of your
budget you would feel in a year you'd
have close to Seven Grand yeah so I look
at things like that and I go okay if I
can quickly come up with five grand
and then I could sell this car and I can
go get a decent car I mean it's an older
it's going to have higher miles but I
can get a car that's going to get me
from point A to point B and it knocks
out a huge chunk of debt man do I have
some wind in my sales I'm always for
fast forwarding the relief and the peace
especially when you got a newborn yeah
you gotta you need a second car pretty
soon so newborn doesn't care how nice
the car is all right he you know and and
quite frankly it doesn't have to be
fancy it just needs to be dependable and
if it does need mechanical work
something that doesn't cost you a ton
it's it's out there so I that's what I
would be doing because I could feel the
pressure on you right now and I think if
you were to relieve 550 a month it would
be massively huge for you what so Caleb
how much does a second job make if you
went back to it
um it's 14 an hour it's part time three
days a week so I make like 250 uh every
week okay so what is a thousand a month
what's that job
fast food
yeah bro I started this fast food when I
was a kid so that's just something safe
and easy to go back to I look into
retail right now I did too I would too
uh even if you got to schlep some tables
I'm telling you man the opportunity for
you to make 20 bucks an hour or more
right now is right in front of you
okay well I make 20 an hour at my first
job should I look to make more yeah
increasing income and selling stuff will
fast forward this really quickly what's
that job the 28 bucks an hour I'm a
welder oh cool
yeah I mean I know I know we're big and
I know like that there is a very high
ceiling for welding but I'm fresh out of
school and I'm I'm trying to get that
six months on my resume like that I'm
trying to be patient trying to let God
do his thing good for him Caleb listen
if I'm you I'm talking to everybody I
know in the welding industry and I'm
looking for side jobs because I think
you getting side jobs as a welder even
though you're young and inexperienced is
going to pay you better than the 14 an
hour fast food thing and more experience
I'm here for it well we're pushing for
you man you got this and uh the way
you've been talking I think we're
getting rid of this car we're saving up
buying a cheap beater right now and uh
that'll get you debt free a whole lot
faster and get you to financial peace
that is the goal thanks for the call